[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Rashad is
with us in Baltimore hi Rashad how are
you hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call Dave and Ken thank you
sure what's
up so me and my wife are a bit at a bit
of a Crossroads with each other and I'm
hoping for some wisdom from you guys
each with uh with each other when it
comes yeah with each other when it comes
to uh our side hustle so we're currently
at on baby step number two where we are
attempting to pay off our debts uh so
that we can eventually save up for our
house and our emergency fund okay um but
at this stage we are kind of hitting a
wall with each other because she keeps
talking about our side hustle she keeps
talking about doing something called
Amazon for uh selling products on Amazon
and you know she keeps talking about
like in buying a house so that we can
eventually invest in real estate which I
know you've done so I'm just hoping for
some guidance because I'm honestly at a
loss and I'm actually a little
terrified uh about losing whatever
little money that we actually do have
right
now okay Amazon Drop Shipping you should
not have to invest any
money is she proposing you invest money
into that
Venture well it's not really it's
basically like how should I put it in
what she what she does is she'll go out
to like department stores and look for
deals on certain products and then sell
it for a no it's just selling at a
higher price yeah that's not Drop
Shipping she's just flipping that's all
she's flipping product so she's going to
tie money up an
inventory correct yes yeah I'll pass
yep yeah so I mean like so for me it's
like I work full-time I have a full-time
job which brings us money
and then I have a part-time job that
brings us money and I'd rather go to my
part-time job that actually brings me
money rather than sit over there and
figure out this this stuff you know
figure out try to try to find products
and I feel like that's just a waste of
time when I can actually devote that
same amount of time to going to work and
actually bringing in a a fixed amount of
money a fixed income and I don't know
how to talk to her about that I don't
know how to make her understand like I
feel like that's a waste of time oh I
think you've said that it just didn't
get
through right you told her that exact
thing didn't
you yes I didn't go had several
arguments argument about it no you got a
messaging issue I I'll just quickly say
this that you know the waste of time
we've already shot that bullet and so we
need to start talking about emotion that
you have the risk of tying up money uh
come at it that way a little bit more
logical with some real emotion instead
of calling what she thinks is cool a
waste yeah it it's um I can't this
terrifies me CU I see us losing money
instead of making money that's different
than you're stupid and this is a waste
of
time so it scares me because I don't
think it's going to work and it bother
and I don't know I don't know how to
talk to you about this because I you
don't seem to see any risk with it but
you could buy a bunch of stuff and it
sits in our garage and that that scares
me I don't want to do that cuz I'm
trying to work so hard to get out of
debt here um if we had some extra money
we wanted to try that that'd be
different but right now we're broke